maintenant une actualité plus
réjouissante le château de Chambord se
prépare à accueillir le Chambord live
festival un événement à 3 millions
d'euros organisés par AZ prod il aura
lieu le 8 septembre prochain avec comme
tête d'affiche le groupe imagine dragons
30 000 personnes sont attendues pour
cette deuxième édition l'année dernière
des spectateurs c'était plein d'avoir
été bloqués plusieurs heures dans les
embouteillages pour sortir du site cette
fois-ci les organisateurs entendent bien
faire mieux explication de Benjamin
Vatel
on est fier de pouvoir créer cet
événement là en région Centre chez nous
j-10 avant le concert d'Imagine dragons
au château de Chambord les 30000 places
se sont vendues en moins de 10 minutes
et les organisateurs présentaient ce
matin les mesures d'accueil du public un
des grands enjeux a été d'améliorer le
dispositif de signalisation des parkings
des bus feront la navette entre la gare
de Blois et le château et le covoiturage
est également très encouragé l'objectif
est d'étaler les arrivées et les départs
des spectateurs pour avoir un trafic
plus fluide que l'an dernier on ouvre le
site à 16 heures contrairement à 2022 on
l'avait indiciaire et on ferme une heure
plus tard donc on a deux heures de plus
une heure avant une heure après donc
évidemment l'idée c'est que le public
arrive le plus tôt possible prenne son
temps le château reste ouvert on m'a
même en place un tarif réduit pour les
porteurs du billet d'Imagine dragons
qu'on peut bénéficier d'un tarif réduit
pour visiter le château toute la journée
le projet est ambitieux mais A à Z prod
le château de Chambord sont confiants
d'accompagner AZ prod et de permettre la
localisation de cet événement dans cette
belle région et pour nous c'est on a
vraiment l'impression de participer à au
soutien de la Région à la valorisation
des dieux les préparatifs pour
accueillir le concert ont déjà commencé
avant l'installation de la scène je dis
7 septembre tous espèrent que le concert
sera aussi réussi que celui de Sting
l'été dernier
[Musique]